bonjour claude heureuse de vous
retrouver dans la matinale berthet
france à quel état des lieux faites-vous
des négociations de vienne et notamment
du retour de l'iran sur ses obligations
eh bien il ya déjà eu six sessions de
négociations est en effet la septième
session devant intervenir très
prochainement
ça va être intéressant de voir comment
elle se déroulera puisque la novation
c'est que les iraniens ont élu un
nouveau président monsieur ibrahim
raïssi qui certes ne prendra ses
fonctions qu'au début du mois d'août
mais qui déjà est crédité d'une certaine
influence mais de toute façon ça ne
devrait pas changer grand chose dans la
négociation de vienne dans les
prochaines semaines puisque c'est
l'ancienne administration
les anciens négociateurs iraniens qui
sont toujours en place et qu'ils
prennent leur instruction politique
auprès du guide suprême l'ayatollah
khatami
alors quels sont les points qui sont en
litige et bien en effet comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure dans votre
sujet l'objectif des iraniens c'est
d'obtenir la levée de toutes les
sanctions américaines contre l'iran
du côté américain on est prêt à lever
les sanctions qui ont été remises en
place par le président tchèque
lorsqu'il a dénoncé l'accord le john tu
comprennes ses voeux plat nos actions
mais les américains veulent garder
certaines sanctions qui ne sont pas
liées à cet accord et c'est une première
difficulté
la deuxième difficulté c'est que eux ils
et les américains souhaiteraient que
parallèlement à la réintégration de
l'iran dans l'accord c'est à dire à la
au respect des obligations notamment de
ne pas enrichir de l'uranium à plus de
3,67 % pour être très loin de la
possibilité d'avoir de l'uranium enrichi
permettant de fabriquer des bombes et
bien en plus de salles et l'américain
voudrais parler du balistique dont on ne
parle pas dans l'accord de juillet 2015
voudra aussi parlé du rôle que joue
l'iran dans un certain nombre de milices
au proche-orient et voudrait aussi
parler de ce qui se passera à
l'expiration cet accord en 2030
or les iraniens disent nous sommes prêts
à respecter toutes nos obligations de
l'accord du 15 juillet 2015
ni plus ni moins par conséquent nous ne
sommes pas prêts à souscrire aujourd'hui
de nouvelles obligations
voilà à peu près quel est l'état de du
dossier ce qui est laisse une assez
grande incertitude sur les chances
d'aboutir
où le risque d'échouer à quel compromis
alors peut-on s'attendre sur les
participants entre les participants à la
négociation claude bon déjà toute la
partie technique du dossier a été
déblayée au cours des six sessions
précédentes
il ya des milliers de pages d'accord y
compris les annexes
parce que c'est ce sont des sujets
extrêmement complexes notamment pour la
vérification du respect des accords mais
reste des points politiques que j'ai
énuméré tout à l'heure et sur lequel en
effet les diplomates ont envisagé des
accords par exemple sur la durée de
l'accord en question est bien comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure
il a été conclu en 2015 pour 15 ans par
conséquent en 2030 il sera caduque
il reste plus que neuf ans devant ces
très courts et les américains voudraient
pouvoir commencer à discuter de la
situation après cet accord et on peut
imaginer que puisque les iraniens
demandent une garantie contre le risque
d'un nouveau retrait des américains de
l'accord par exemple dans quatre ans
lorsqu'il aura un nouveau président
américain
et on peut imaginer si les républicains
rejettent au pouvoir que les américains
se retirent à nouveau de l'accord
les iraniens veulent se garantir contre
ce risque on pourrait trouver une
formule diplomatique où il y aurait une
forme d'engagement américain à respecter
l'accord jusqu'à son échéance 2030
mais en contrepartie on ouvrirait dès
maintenant des discussions sur
l'évolution ensuite l'évolution vers un
nouvel accord après 2030 c'est un
compromis envisageable
la même façon sur le balistique il est
possible d'envisager l'ouverture d'une
discussion après tout libre aux iraniens
de bloquer cette discussion ou de la
rendre dans ce potentiel de la même
manière pour les le rôle qu'il joue à
l'égard du hezbollah ou à l'égard
d'autres groupements politiques au
proche orient
la question est plutôt de savoir si
khatami donc le décideur suprême en
matière politique en iran est prêt à
faire des concessions optique ou pas et
l'enjeu politique est important pour lui
mais il ya un autre enjeu politique
peut-être qui est plus urgent qui est de
faire lever les sanctions économiques
parce que la population iranienne n'en
peut plus de ces sanctions économiques
ils sont assez efficaces les iraniens
eux mêmes ont dit qu'un accord technique
était prêt dans des domaines clés comme
le pétrole comme le transport a comme
les assurances et quels sont les
principaux obstacles finalement un
accord global
le principal on l'a vu sur votre sujet c
est évidemment que israël est totalement
hostile à cet accord depuis le début
d'ailleurs c'est une grande constante de
la politique israélienne et israël
israël est prêt à torpiller cet accord
quoi qu'il arrive
soulagés du fait qu'on en soit sorti
effectivement ils considèrent que les
états unis ne doivent pas à réintégrer
cet accord qu'il faut maintenir la
pression maximum sur les rangs et par
conséquent maintenir les sanctions
à part cette position très marquée
d'israël il y à la position des
républicains au congrès qui évidemment
vous regarder de très près le contenu de
l'accord si un accord
rien dans les prochaines semaines et qui
sont très attentifs à ce que les états
unis et obtenu des garanties notamment
sur les trois sujets que j'ai cités tout
à l'heure que se passera-t-il après 2030
que quid des missiles balistiques et et
quid de l'influencé iranienne mais dans
un certain nombre de pays du proche
orient et le congrès américain pourrait
refuser de ratifier un accord qui ne lui
conviendrait pas alors les américains en
fait considère qu' il faut conclure
rapidement
et en effet je crois que tout le monde
considère aujourd'hui que le temps
travaille contre le retour des
américains à l'accord et la levée des
sanctions des sanctions occidentales à
l'égard de l'iran alors qui peut aider à
la conclusion de cet accord
eh bien il ya les autres participants à
la conférence de genève les français les
allemands les britanniques mais aussi
les russes aussi les chinois
et là dessus on ne sait pas exactement
quelle est la position chinoise au bout
du compte est ce que les chinois
souhaitent véritablement la conclusion
d'un accord à genève dans les prochaines
semaines ou pas c'est peut-être là que
se trouve le noeud de la question merci
beaucoup claude pour toutes ces
explications un claude blanchemaison un
spécialiste en relations internationales
c'est l édito diplôme de la matinale